اللي متابع تفاعلكم اكيد عارف انه ما يكسب
من نجوم المفضلين كفريق وضيفه دائما معانا
مع كل عمل وكل موسم بتبدع فيه في رمضان
هذا اتالق طبعا في دور ثريا في جعفر
العمده
لو الوضع عايش رجعه لي ولو ميت ورينا فين
اللي
[موسيقى]
الايس كريم
[تصفيق]
لعبه يا الغيبه
في رمضان عن بعد وعدتنا بزياره واليوم
بتوفي بالوعد ومنورتنا في الاستوديو
النجمه مي كساب اهلا فيكي معايا يا ميس
يعني انا مو سر محبتي لك وانحياز لك اصلا
بشكل عام كل سنه تعرفي انك انت مفضله عندي
صحيح ورمضان ده ثريا اعتقد كلنا
يعني كان نجاح غير مسبوق نقدر نقول في اي
شيء كمسلسل لكم كلكم كل شيء كان فيه غير
مسبوق حسيتي بهذا الشيء اه طبعا كان نجاح
ساحق خصوصا وحاله منفرده حصلت في الشارع
المصري والشارع العربي وهي تفاعل الجمهور
معانا يعني بقى الجمهور فارق معاه امتى
بقى هتشوفي ابنك يعني كانت حلقه غريبه
واول مره تحصل اظن وشفتي كميه التعليقات
اللي طلعت على الدور ايش في كذا شيء مثلا
ضحكك شفتيه وضحكك اهو اكثر حاجه ضحكتني
قوي لما انا غني ت الرباعيه وعملوا صور لي
انا واحمد سعد اللي هو ارجع ده ابني انا
ههه احمد سعد لان هو كان بيغني في مسلسل
عجبتني قوي جدا ضحكتني جدا وعلى سيره
الرباعيه هادي كيف جاء موضوع انك انت اللي
تعميها ويعني ايش القصه من وراهم محمد
سامي طبعا يعني
هو فكر من الاول ان رباعياتكم بصوتي اصدق
يعني وطبعا لان هو شايفني كمطربه مقصره في
حق الغناء فدلوقتي بيقول لي بقى انت
تحولتي للممثله اللي هترجع بقى تغني تغني
محمد سامي يعني بيشوف اشياء وبيفرضها يعني
بحبها خلاص ايوه فعلا صاحب وجهه نظر
منفرده يعني حقه ايوه طب نقدر نسمع شيء من
الرباعيه اه طبعا
رجع حبيبي عيني
نبض اللي تهمني
يا اه
فرقيني
ويا هم غيب عني
[موسيقى]
ارضي اللي كانت بوك من حضنه طرحت نور يا
قلبي يابا
[موسيقى]
انسى الوجع اغني
يا قلبي يا ما
اقول انسى الوج
عني
الله يعطيك العافيه شكرا
المسلسل كمان يعني زي ما النجاح كان كبير
برضو ده من كان في كلامه اشياء من كده
دايما دحين بيقولوا انه دائما بيجيبوا
سيرتك انت وايمان العاصي وطبعا منا فضالي
والكبيره طبعا هلا صدقي تحيه لهم كلهم
طبعا الملكه هلا صدقي لكن دايما في كلام
ما بتجيبوا سيره زينه ما بتنزلوا صور زينه
ما بتحطوا زينه ابدا معكم في الكلام انا
هتكلم عن نفسي انا زينه صديقه من زمان جدا
ليا يعني حتى من قبل ما نبقى مشهوره قوي
وهي تبقى مشهوره قوي لسه صغيرين في
بدايتنا
وزنا انسانه محترمه جدا وانا بعتز
بصداقتها وما فيش اي مشاكل بينا احنا بس
كان يعني اغلبيه التصوير هي ما بتكونش
موجوده معانا فيه بس عشان كده ما كانش في
صور بتحصل يعني بتجمعنا كلكم مجتمعين اكتر
يعني
بجد واحنا كلنا قلنا الكلام ده ما كانش في
اي مشاكل الحمد لله كانت الاجواء كويسه
جدا بيننا وده على الشاشه ما كانش ربنا
هيكرمنا كل الكرم الكبير ده لو بان حتى
بعدين وانتم بتحتفوا ببعض والنجاح
والبوستات لما كل واحده فيكم كانت تيجي
اللحظه اللي دورها بيصير فيه التحول كان
يعني الكل بيقلب معاها وبيساندها والكلام
ده كله لا سويته يعني شغل حلو على
السوشيال ميديا صراحه يعني تفاعلنا مع
الشاشه ومع السوشيال ميديا مع حساباتكم بس
كمان صار كلام كثير على موضوع التتر وحتى
انت قلتي انا استاهل انه يكون اسمي بعد
محمد رمضان طيب نقدر نقول انه انت مثلا في
المسلسلك الجاي حتى شطرطي انه اسمك مثلا
يكون اول اسم ثاني اسم او كيف بدك هو دي
امور يعني انا بشوف انها لازم تتحل الاول
مع الانتاج قبل ما ندخل في العمل فانا
مثلا كل سنه بتعلم حاجه فاحنا السنه دي بس
كانت المشكله كبيره لان 3/ نجوم وعمل
مليان بالظبط وكل واحد بيشيل المسلسل
لوحده فكان يعني انا يعني عذرا الانتاج
والله يعني هم كانوا مش عارفين يعملوا ايه
يرضوا مين ولا بس دي حاجه بتبقى مهمه
بالنسبه لنا احنا كفنانين لكن للجمهور ما
بتبقاش مهمه خالص يعني الجمهور لا يعنيه
مين اسمه قبل مين جمهور يعني ايه مين احسن
واحد يعني على فكره انا عمري ما انتبهت
اسمي هذا الا بلا ما تبدا تصير مشاكل افتح
واتفرجت
نفسيه عندنا احنا وما بنعرفش نتخلص منها
ابدا يعني ابدا حتى انت حتى انا فنانه زيي
زيهم بالظبط اللي ممكن ياخدونه تعكس
التقدير او الوضع اللي وصل له الواحد
في القتال من اجل الموضوع ده يعني انا
يعني شخص ما بيقدرش يفضل في في فرقه اه
يعني وانا بفضل بقى خاطر بعمل مشاكل عشان
الحاجات دي فانا يعني لما الاقي الموضوع
حيطه سد خلاص يعني ما بفضلش معنديش نفس
للخناقه في النهايه الناس بتتكلم عن اشخاص
في المسلسل
ايوه واللعبه يعني كان متوقع ينزل في
رمضان ايش اللي رمضان قبل رمضان كمان احنا
دايما موعدنا
ده قرار من شاهد مش مننا احنا خالص اه
يعني ده قرار مسلسل لان كمان اعتقد شاهد
كان عندهم اعمال كتيره قبل رمضان ناجحه
فغالبا الريت كان عالي قوي علشان شاهد
فاعتقد بدماغ انتاجيه شويه يعني هم قالوا
الريت في رمضان عالي على شاهد فقال لك
اعليه بعد رمضان ازاي طبعا باللعبه لان
احنا يعني ما شاء الله اللعبه طول السنه
مش بس فتره معينه لو دحينا الحلو انه
الناس لما الرابع نزل بداوا يحضروا من
الاول اللي فاتهم بداوا يرجعوا يحضروا من
الاول بس تفضلي انه ينزل في رمضان
يعني هي المنافسه في رمضان بيبقى لها طعم
مختلف بس انا جعفر العمده اكيد ما كنتش
عايزه حاجه تشوش على الدور لان اوريدي
جالي مسلسل تاني بطولتي
يعني اعمله ورفض خلاص واخذوا احد ثاني
انعرض المسلسل لا اظن ما عملوش المسلسل
خالص بس خفت ورفضت وكده واعتذرت لرمضان
الجاي يمكن يا رب
رمضان الجاي ده حاجه مخوفانا كلنا يعني
احنا جبنا السقف اه شايفه هنروح فين طيب
اوكي والشيء الاساس ده احنا سمعناكي
بتغنيه يعني ليه ما بترجعي بتغني
هو غصب عني شويه يعني انا يمكن الوقت اللي
غنيت فيه كانت مقاييس الساحه الغنائيه لها
مقاييس معينه وانا دايما بقول بصراحه ان
احنا كان مطربين بنفتقد المنتج الفنان انا
طول عمري نفسي اقابل منتج فنان ياخد
الموهبه ويدير الموهبه دي كويس جدا
ويعتبرها مشروعه احنا كلنا كمطربين كل
النجاحات دي اجتهادات فرديه ما فيش مؤسسه
بتشتغل عليكي وتدعمك وتقول مثلا انا عندي
مي كساب مي كساب فنانه شامله بتغني وبتمثل
يعني روتانا انا كليا تجربه معاهم وليهم
كل التقدير والاحترام بس كمان كان حظي سيء
معهم لان انا في الوقت اللي عملت فيه
لقلبه مع روتانا على اللي هو احلى من
الكلام بعدها هم قرروا غالبا يقفلوا فرع
القاهره او حاجه كده فما كملناش
طيب
نقدر نسمع شويه طيب نختم كده بشيء من صوتك
الحلو جوزي بيحبها اوكي طيب
تحيه طبعا
وانا لسه هصبر تاني عليك واعد وازيد غلطي
تاني انا كل مره اخد بايديك بلاقيك نسيت
في ثواني
وانا يوم ما هتعب مش هلاقيك ولا يوم
تعيشها
عشاني يا وجع قلبي كل يوم بهواك يا تعب
قلبي هعمل ايه وياك هو اللي ضحى حبيبي
معاك تكافئه
بعذابه يا وجع قلبي ليه في ناري تقيد
لتيجي وتمشي من بعيد لبعيد وكمان
عايزني انا ات
يا جرحني
بغيابك
الله الله الله الله انا بس حابه اقول لك
حاجه هو كانوا جالسين في الجاليه دي كلهم
بداوا يطلبوا طلبات اغاني والكلام ده كله
فنتجاهلتهم وخلتك انت اللي تختاري انت
اخترتي شيء هم كان بدهم اياه صراحه ايوه
بس اوري حاجه انه انا وانت بتغني انا شلت
السماعه من اذني لانه بداوا يغنوا يا
حبايبي
شكرا لكم يعني انت رائعه رائعه رائعه
حبيبتي
شكرا لك كانت معنا طبعا النجمه مي